it's really rewarding to put in the work
and practice every day and then when you
go to a really big competition
just to see how much you improve and all
the progress you make
a really good friend of mine convinced me to do cross
country and I stuck with it and during
spring you go to track and I figured you
know why not? Running the 400 hurdles is
very rhythmic. It used to feel sort of
smooth and easy in the beginning and
then hard at the end but now it's all
starting to feel the same speed
it's really really awesome going to the
Olympic Trials not only representing
Harvard but also with my teammates just
because it's really nice to be able to
wear that H. Reaching for the Olympics is
definitely my riskiest goal so far
I kind of came to the realization like,
whoa, I'm on the road to Rio, like i am
I'm actually trying to do this
taking a step back and kind of looking
at what I've been doing
how far I've come it's happening really
fast but it's a lot of fun
that's what I like about it, you know,
discovering new things about myself
Harvard has helped me get to this
point because it really fosters this
hard-working person that I've become. Everything that I do is not fifty percent
in the classroom, you have
to give everything one hundred percent
at the track you definitely have to give a hundred percent
going to the trials is a great
experience for athletes even if they
don't hit the Olympic standard just
because it's really great competition
really high energy high caliber high
stakes
we have a pretty competitive US team
so just to be able to even compete for a
spot on that is such a privilege and an
honor to be able to represent the u.s.
at the Olympics would be really special
it would be amazing to wear your country
on your chest and represent your country